well today we are learning more about a
murder-suicide investigation that
involves a police officer now take a
look here on your screen this happened
near
west lake mead in north las vegas
neighbors telling us they were shocked
to see this scene play out outside of
their home and a bigger surprise when
they learned that their neighbor was
part of law enforcement
this was the scene sunday morning that
many neighbors tell us felt chaotic
dozens of police officers including the
swat team blocking all access on
perryville avenue a gated community in
north las vegas and rattling nerves for
neighbors like mark harris all i heard
was a big boom
then they woke me up and
i thought it was fireworks according to
north las vegas police an off-duty
officer got into an argument with his
wife sunday morning after a night out as
the man threatened to kill his wife and
daughter their son was shot in the hand
that's when the wife and son ran out of
the home to get help she ran around that
corner
because they had those cones they had
those cones all the way around the
corner the blood spot i guess that's
probably from her son's hand police say
around four in the morning the off-duty
officer shot his daughter and himself
inside the home harris says the officer
he knew as easy kept to himself so much
he didn't know he was a police officer
he always working out he always speaking
to my grandkids
even his wife was always working out
together riding the bikes together
so
he was
he was a good cat this video shared to 8
news now by a resident who doesn't want
to be identified shows several police
officers around the home moments later
the garage door is blown out as officers
forced their way inside they tore it up
they tore the garage up and the windows
were all busted out yes i saw it
yeah and you're looking on the outside
oh they're living good they're doing
great but on the inside
something going on
well both the identity of the officer
and his daughter have yet to be released
now we do want to remind you that there
is a new 988 suicide hotline available
right now if you or anyone you know
needs help